we've all
come in contact with corporations you
might work for a corporation you might
buy something from a corporation you
might uh i don't know you might own
shares in a corporation so we kind of
have a sense of what they are but i want
to make that sense a little bit more
precise in this video and also give an
understanding of why corporations even
exist
and so a corporation and you might
already kind of have a feeling for this
it's a legal entity
it's a legal entity
that can kind of act that can act
that can act like a person
like a person i put the act in quotes
because obviously there are some things
that a person can do that a corporation
can't a person can smile i guess one
could debate whether a corporation can
when i say act i mean legally so a
corporation can sue another corporation
or a person a corporation can be sued by
another corporation or a person a
corporation can own things just like a
person owns things a corporation can owe
other people or corporations things so
that's what i mean by act a corporation
can't jump like a person or laugh like a
person well that maybe that will be a
philosophical discussion for another
video but what i want to focus on other
than just what a corporation is is why
they exist so what's the why of a
corporation and in my mind there's two
big reasons and the first reason this is
the real the biggest one is limited
liability sounds like a very fancy word
but we'll see it with an example it's
not too it's not too fancy
so there's limited liability and there's
also kind of transferable share
ownership
share
ownership
but what i want to do in this which is
you know essentially more than one
person can own the corporation they can
transfer the shares between people they
can trade them but what i want to focus
on is a limited liability because even
if there's only one person who owns the
corporation if they own the whole thing
it still makes sense for them to create
it because of limited liability and to
understand this let me give you a little
example let's say that let's let's say
that there's some guy let's say his bill
let's say it's bill's
bill's assets right over here
and let's say that he has a house
let's say that he has a house
that is worth five hundred thousand
dollars
let's say that he has a car maybe he has
a very nice car let's say he has a car
that is worth
100 that's too much for a car that's
very well cars can cost that much but
let's be 50 000 is still a nice car
let's say that he has some investments
some investment properties or maybe some
stocks that are worth another
another 500 000
and let's say that he's interested you
know he looks around his town he sees
that there's a lot of people who could
use a ride so to make some extra money
he wants to start a a cab or car service
business so he goes out there and he
doesn't think about starting a
corporation and he just goes out there
and he buys a car let me call a cab plus
licenses
a cab plus licenses and uh these things
are actually much more expensive than
you would imagine you could you could
talk to a the next time you're in a cab
it costs much more than the cost of the
car which would probably be 20 or 30
thousand dollars it comes up close to
six figures but let's say that it costs
him
eighty thousand dollars
and let's say that he spends one
thousand dollars at least for this first
year let's say he spends one thousand
dollars on insurance on liability
insurance he's he realizes hey look
maybe you know maybe something bad
happens this is a cab i could run into
somebody and i get sued so i want to get
liability insurance so this is liability
insurance in case anything like that
happens and let's say that it is a
let's say that it is a hundred thousand
dollar policy he says you know how can i
you know there's
he's maybe a little bit optimistic and
he thinks that no one can sue him for
more than a hundred thousand dollars
so it is a hundred thousand dollar
it is a hundred thousand dollar policy
now he goes out there he starts driving
that cab around picking up people
dropping them off and by accident one
day he rolls over someone's foot
and that person whose foot he just
crushed happened to be a a you know a
world-class soccer player so he ruined
this person's career
he ruined the career so right here
here's the soccer
the soccer player right over here whose
career is ruined or if that you're
watching this outside of the
the united states a football player but
anyway you have this soccer player his
crush his his his his his his foot is
crushed and so he sues bill he's because
bill owns owns the cab
and the court so he sues let me write it
he sues bill
sue's bill
for
one million dollars
one million dollars because it ruined
his career in fact that's probably
probably deserves more than that if he
was a world-class player and the court
you know rightfully says look you
crushed this guy's player you you were
kind of this guy's foot you were kind of
negligent you got a little bit too close
to the curb and his foot was crushed so
it rules in the soccer player's favor
and so essentially now bill's on the
line for the entire million dollars so
bill's going to have to sell his house
he's going to have to sell his car well
actually he wouldn't have to sell his
car because he has investments sell his
investments and give his house or the
the proceeds from his house and
investment to the soccer player
and so now all bill's left with is a car
and a cab and not much else so what did
this this this cab business didn't work
out too well for bills a small part of
his portfolio he didn't have even a
chance to make much money from it and it
really just wiped him clean now what
bill should have done is create a
separate corporation
is create a separate corporation
called
called bills
bills car service
car service
inc
and transferred enough money so that the
cabs licenses and insurance could be
owned by this legal entity by this
corporation so here you would have the
cabs
cab plus the license
so he would have transferred 80 000 to
the corporation and the corporation
would have bought it in the
corporation's name remember it can act
like a person it can buy things in its
name the owner of this cab is bill's car
service not bill it could also get the
insurance
the hundred thousand dollars of
insurance maybe this is what people
think is a reasonable amount for anyone
who's running a cabinet you have to have
at least a hundred thousand the reality
is probably it's a much larger number
than that and he spends one thousand
dollars to have that policy and remember
this is a hundred thousand dollars of
liability insurance now let's play out
the same situation the cab still rolls
over the soccer player's foot the soccer
player's foot gets crushed can't play
soccer anymore sues whoever owned that
cab for a million dollars but now the
owner of that cab is no longer bill it's
the bill's car service so he sues this
sue's bill's car service and let me make
clear in this reality bill's assets
wouldn't include the cab the licenses
and the insurance anymore it would now
include 100 percent
ownership
ownership
of
car
service
of bill's car service so the asset is
now the shares the 100 ownership in this
but this is a separate legal entity so
now the soccer player sues the cab
service for a million dollars the court
rightfully says hey yeah you owe this
dude a million dollars you ruined his
career
but unfortunate for the player and i
guess fortunate for bill and i don't
want to take sides here this is just how
reality is set up and this is what
limited liability is
is that now
all all the car service can produce is
well they could sell they could sell
maybe these assets for eighty thousand
dollars and they'll get a hundred
thousand dollars they'll get a hundred
thousand dollars from the insurance so
all this corporation is going to be able
to do is give the guy
180 000
and then the corporation is just going
to go bankrupt
so it's going to declare corporate
bankruptcy
it's going to go
bankrupt so this thing that bill owed
this car service which maybe originally
he could write on his books as being
worth 81 thousand dollars had insurance
policy and all this other stuff
it's now worth a zero the corporation's
worth zero
but the soccer player can't go after
anything else we'll talk about in the
future of re reasons why they can if he
didn't have enough insurance or if he
didn't if he was running this like his
own personal business if this car
service didn't have its own bank account
or if it didn't if it was under
capitalized if it didn't have enough
money in it
then maybe the court would let the
soccer player or kind of pierce the
corporate veil they say which is a very
fancy way of still going after the
owners of the corporation but as long as
this corporation was reasonably
capitalized and i just made up these
numbers here the soccer player will only
be able to go after this corporation so
what you see here is that bill's
liability was limited this was limited
liability the most he could lose as long
as he ran the car service properly and
put had enough insurance and had enough
money in the in in the actual
organization as long as he ran it in the
right way the most he could lose is the
value of the organization and if this
organization you know hit somebody or
rolled over their foot
it they and he when he ran the
organization properly they can't go out
over the rest of his assets so this is
the number one reason why people have
corporations for the limited liability